attention roulement de tambour
alors Géraldine je le connais bien parce
que c'est une journaliste de Lina de
l'Institut national du visuel avec qui
j'ai travaillé et en matinale et en
matinale à la France Info
un petit partenariat qui commence ce
soir avec Lina une fois par mois et bien
on aura un une journée de Lina qui
viendra avec des archives je crois qu'on
aura quatre ce soir exactement 4 ce soir
donc des images du passé parfois de des
années 80 parfois mais en plus
et ici il y a des consommateurs des
amoureux de vendre consommateurs
extraordinaire moi je peux vraiment
passer des heures sur le site de Lina
c'est c'est extraordinaire et tu as des
pépites sur des faits de société moi je
pense à des micro-trottoirs te voir un
peu comment les gamins les loquences
qu'ils avaient il y a 45 ans dans les
années 60 c'est super intéressant parce
que ça permet de voir aussi comment la
société a évolué au travers les
décennies